un banquet en compagnie de compteurs et
de troubadours c'est ce que propose la
forteresse de Montbazon trois fois par
an durant les beaux jours le premier
avait lieu ce week-end près d'une
centaine de conviviés étaient au
rendez-vous au programme concert de
ménestrel combat en armure et dîner au
feu de bois Léa Turquie nous embarque
tout droit au Moyen-Âge regardez
[Musique]
un plongeon dans l'époque médiévale et
ça commence en musique surtout un verre
à la main de l'Hippocrate un cocktail du
Moyen-Âge à base de vin et d'épices à
l'Hippocrate c'est merveilleux c'est
très bien les jeunes gens sont
magnifiques et puis j'adore la
féministrée un peu j'aime beaucoup ça de
Montbazon en cette belle soirée vous
offre un combat entre deux beaux
chevaliers d'un côté Jarod le flamboyant
de l'autre Charlie le rouge et chacun
avec 20 à 30 kg d'armure sur le dos de
quoi totalement fasciné le public
c'était comment le combat
j'ai la plaqué deux fois ils y vont pas
de main morte c'est ça nous a choqué
presque j'ai trouvé que c'était
vachement bien fait impressionnant car
c'est une réelle discipline et son nom
c'est le boh nos armures sont des
reproduction historiques mais le combat
lui n'est pas chorégraphié c'est
vraiment les portes on donne des vrais
coups avec que ce soit avec des épées DH
des masses à ailettes comme Jarod les
coups sont vraiment portés
il est maintenant l'heure du repas
tenant leur du
banc des animations
la nuit tombe le jambonneau grillé au
feu de bois est servi ce retour dans le
temps à la forteresse de Montbazon c'est
incontournable depuis plusieurs années
c'est un moment d'évasion mais
d'apporter quelque chose d'assez unique
en soi de profiter d'une soirée
conviviale avec une vue différente de
des visites habituelles quoi l'immersion
s'achève par la visite du plus vieux
donjon de France à l'allure des
flambeaux pour la soirée comptez une
quarantaine d'euros par adulte les
prochains banquiers à la forteresse de
Montbazon seront le 14 juillet et le 14
août